a number of commentators over the last
decade maybe two decades have talked
about what I think of a skills
development I mean do you have the
requisite skills to be able to enter
your first job can you read well can you
write well do you have the ability to
code etc I actually think we often times
confuse skills and skills development
with education in education is actually
designed to actually encourage the
individual to consider questions they
hadn't considered before to actually be
able to assemble a vast minh array of
information and then to synthesize that
information and to come up with perhaps
what one would think of as new answers
it's not about learning the most recent
technique and the challenges is that if
you only talk about skills development
the way knowledge is produced these days
our generation is 18 months and so that
means about the time you've actually
finished school oftentimes you're
already behind a curve and some of that
information is obsolete if you're really
truly educated you then learn and you
know how to go about pursuing the new
acquisition of information and that
information that you can then synthesize
and apply to what you already know means
then that you're not behind the curve
you're keeping pace with the change
that's always occurring in both in
technology and other aspects of American
life
I love STEM science technology
engineering and math I actually can
remember circa 1998 being at a meeting
at the National Science Foundation and
it wasn't even stem yet it was cement
SMPT science math engineering and
technology and we were all sitting there
gone you sure you want to call this met
and we came back a year later and and it
turned from being Smet to stem and we go
why is it now stem and that's met and
they said well believe it or not we were
up on Capitol Hill
asking for money for Smet and if one
Congress person a goes why do we want
money for smut misunderstanding and miss
hearing what was being said and they
realized at that point they needed to re
order in the alphabet and so hence was
born stem the long story
is that actually it still took another
six or seven years for stem to actually
gain some traction because a lot of both
public policymakers and others thought
of stem as related to stem cell research
and they were hesitant to get into the
political cultural wars over stem cell
and stem cell research my colleagues in
the sciences persevered and we now hear
all over the place that we need to make
investments in science technology
engineering and math what I actually
believe we need to do so I also realize
that but I think of these Grand
Challenges in the world these gnarly
problems that require us to really
mobilize a whole array of talent and
research we can't answer those questions
only by asking what a scientist would
think of it or an engineer mean the
example I give is one of my favorite
examples I was in a meeting in Atlanta
some years ago when I was still at Emory
University and we were over at Georgia
Tech and I friends the Georgia Tech and
colleagues from Emory and former
officials from the CDC were sitting in
the water in Rome talking about water
and the need to come up with a solution
to clean water and they were telling the
story about a West African village and
in this West African village there was a
need for clean water
the women would trek every day down to
the river that was contaminated and that
was actually leading to all kinds of
infections that could be prevented so
one of the international agencies
provided research and dollars for them
to then drill well when the engineers
came in did their survey and drilled the
wealth right in the middle of the
village to their surprise the women
walked past a well and kept going to the
contaminated River and in the engineers
were mystified finally engineers thought
well maybe we should bring in some
anthropologist and gender experts to
talk to the women they finally did and
they asked the women a simple question
why are you walking past a well and
they're perfectly clean water to go to
the river with the contaminated water
and the women says look we understand
that this water is better here but you
don't understand why we walk through the
water it's not only a utilitarian
function or retrieving water it's a
way for us to get away from the mem folk
in the village from the children to
break up the routine of the domestic
household for us to have them this whale
right there actually doesn't serve our
purposes and so they actually moved the
well they drilled it farther away to
both assist of women and allow them to
have their cultural practices maintained
and to also provide clean water but it's
a case where in this case the scientists
need humanists and a humanist need a
scientist and as I think about the kind
of problems that we craft and the ones
that we identify really it's really
about what is the question being posed
who are the best interlocutors to be
part of answering that question and how
do we go about assembling the team and
so for me at the very least stem is
important but all over the place when we
look at those grand challenges those
gnarly problems I do come away thinking
scientists need humanists and humanists
nee scientists and we need both to help
us solve these problems